what do you think about the seeming fact
the majority of Palestinians support the
October 7th attacks you have to see the
world their world through their eyes you
can't try to see their world through
your
eyes if you live under
occupation you're routinely
harassed at Israeli
checkpoints the occupation is expanding
into your ter territory you're meeting
families you know regularly that have
been thrown out of their homes and that
are looking for a new place in the
shrinking territory you deal with
routine air strikes you have no way to
get out you have no way to grow you
don't even have a passport your
education is subpar your standards of
living are lower than the rest of the
world and all you hear from the other
side which dominates the discourse and
dominates every element of your
existence are Promises of eraser of
complete
eraser 13,000 people I mentioned
13,000 new settlement units being
Advanced if that happened anywhere right
just think about what that means right
when you clear out a village or
two and it's not that big of a territory
right when you know that that's
happening and when you have been
subjected to
that anyone that claims to be supporting
you or uplifting you from that state of
misery is going to have sympathy whether
you agree with their mission or their
methods or not it's human it is human
that if anyone says that they are going
to get you out of this misery and
inflict pain on those who have given you
a life of pain and promised you a future
of pain you're going to have sympathy to
that group whether you agree with them
or not not I think that the question
also has to be
asked what about the Israeli public
Israel holds all of the power in that
region holds all the power over that
territory is able to dominate the
expansion of its own territory and
diminish any Palestinian territory is
able to PR Place restrictions whenever
it wants on Palestinian movement trying
to get to their holy sites or otherwise
whether it's m AA or the holy supper of
theur chur of nativity
right the majority of the Israeli
public before October 7th
unfortunately according to all polls
favors a non-democratic regime the end
of a two-state
solution does not care about the plight
of Palestinian people the majority of
the Israeli public why is that and what
does that mean for Palestinians right
especially now after this genocide the
vast majority of the Israeli public does
not favor a ceasefire
right what are we supposed to do when we
see mainstream media coming out of
Israel pop culture uh Tik Tock videos
that only speak to a greater desire to
eliminate the Palestinian people right
so anyone that says that they are going
to support your plight whether you agree
with their mission or their methods is
going to resonate with that child that
has grown up in those desperate
circumstances you know basam Yousef had
an interview with Pierce Morgan and he
was talking about this I mean just he he
literally gave it a human a human story
if you're a child that's grown up you've
lost limbs your parents are dead Your
Friends Are Dead you have been made a
refugee two or three times
already you have no future in
sight and then someone comes to you and
says I'm going to help you and I'm going
to fight back on your beh have of course
it's going to resonate it's human right
and so I think that it's important for
us to see the world through their eyes
rather than trying to see the world
through our
eyes so as Malcolm X did you're calling
for highlighting the asymmetry in
violence and asymmetry in moral
reasoning
absolutely it's important you're not
going to be able to solve this problem
unless you're able to do that and so
when when said uh that if you stick a
knife 9 in into my back and pull it out
in that's not progress progress is
healing the wounds and you're not even
willing to acknowledge that the knife is
there yet those that don't acknowledge
what is determined Now by any uh
international human rights organization
even Israeli human rights
organization uh bet Islam and others to
be apartheid a state of aparte and a
state of occupation
and now an unfolding
genocide
um you know are are not Partners For
Peace it just hurts me to
think how long it takes to
heal even if the Healing Begins now with
a
knife
metaphor it's just going to be
Generations because people don't forget
when your father and mother were
murdered or somebody that you know in
your family was killed they don't
forget
look I think the point is is that we
have to come to terms with the fact
that the trauma of the
past does not justify the murder of the
present and the fear of the future does
not justify the murder of of the present
the urgency of the world right now
should be entirely focused on ending
this atrocity that unfortunately the
world has become so complacent with
again prior to October 7th this status
quo was not acceptable and there was no
means in sight in the global Arena to re
the in to make Israel more accountable
to stop
this I do believe in the power of
healing I do believe in the power of
growth I I do believe that we have seen
ugly episodes of History
before that have been rectified I also
believe in the heart of my people I
believe that the Palestinian People Are
People of resistance they're people of
resilience they're people of courage and
there are people of benevolence and
magnam minity and there are people who
have been made to grow under the worst
of
circumstances I don't see in in the
hearts of young Palestinians that have
been tormented I don't see Darkness I
see light I see the ability to still
laugh and find Joy despite everything
that's
happened and so I think that the urgency
right now just has to be towards
ensuring that they have a life that
they're not being killed anymore